mike is it true that you are part of a
Guinness Book of World Records
designation almost it's it's actually
part of record setter so record setter
calm has it's like you know its own
world records and I have a world record
for the most amount of jumping photos
ever taken so I have thousands of
photographs of people jumping just to
jump it's sort of like a thing and on
flickr you can find an entire community
now we have over 25,000 people that are
part of the jumping project where people
shoot photographs of people jumping and
how did you get involved with that
that's interesting uh just my passion
for shooting photos so like way way back
in the day when I was much younger we
used to do this thing called freerunning
which has now become what's known as
parkour right where people are you know
kind of jumping over obstacles or doing
a spin or doing a flip over something so
I used to do a lot of jumping stuff like
that myself and when I got into
photography it was always like oh you
know let's I don't know so I in the
early days of Flickr i was just
fascinated by these jump shots and so I
kind of got involved and started
shooting my own jump shots and every
time I had some friends over or a group
we do a jump shot and so ultimately I
just became like the number one of this
whole group and submitted my record to
record setter and what was really cool
as they actually published a full record
setter book last year and I actually got
included in the book with my world
record so in part of the videos that I
watched your your collage of 2010-2011
travels I noticed that when you'd meet
up with people you would do these jump
shots yeah and so what are some tips you
could tell other people if they wanted
to do jump shots do you get like them
what how much of a running start are
they getting well you want to jump in
place I feel fine because that's where
your focus is on your camera and I shoot
with the digital SLR so I'm always
shooting like a couple frames
and so yeah you basically say jump and
you get your focus locked and you say
jump and if you hold your camera a
little bit lower you know you'll get
that perspective shift where it looks
like the jump is a little bit higher
which I find fascinating I've set up my
own jump shots where I'm like trying to
jump over a landmark or a physical thing
wave in the background and I just have
to like get the right thing and jump
over it so it looks like I'm in the sky
but the coolest thing about a jump shot
is you really can't do a jump shot in a
bad mood and I feel like when you do a
jump shot the person because they're
jumping naturally becomes like joyous or
happy or just there you can't do
something else in that moment you're
just jumping in that moment it's just
for the pleasure of jumping interesting
there's no miserable jumpers yeah so how
did you find out about the Flickr group
you just went on flickr and you just be
a part of it yeah back in the early days
of flickr it was like wow it's like you
know the internet kind of evolves and
like the idea of like oh i'm going to
share my photos and they're just going
to be there for people to see was sort
of this new idea before that it was sort
of like oh it's mine and you know it's
copyrighted and I have it but yeah I
don't want to share it and Flickr kind
of became this sharing community where
people upload their photos and you can
favorite photos and you can make groups
and and yeah so ended up in this flickr
group and yeah and do you get together
and go on excursions with some of the
la-based people or even across the
country yeah there's what's called photo
walking which is sort of like
photographers will get together and
we'll all go photo walking where you
just shoot all together and shoot cool
stuff and I've gone on a couple of
different photo walks where we've all
met down at the beach and we've you know
just gone shot the santa monica pier or
stuff like that
you